.
Das Paradies gibt es nirgends.
Es ist nie genau so, wie man es sich
wünscht. Das ist eine Illusion.
Ich war von Anfang an griechischer.
* Vogelzwitschern *
Während der Arbeit
kann man zwischendurch
mal für 5 Min.
das Rauschen des Bachs geniessen.
In der Schweiz herrschte ein per-
manenter Druck - tack, tack, tack.
(Frau, Englisch)
(Mann) Wir sind jetzt
seit knapp zwei Jahren hier.
Wir erlebten sehr viel Unschönes,
konnten jedoch weitermachen.
Jetzt aufzugeben,
wäre wirklich keine Option.
Es ist nicht Bullerbü-Schweden.
- Das ist halt so.
Wir kauften
eine alte Anlage und wussten,
dass einiges auf uns zukommt.
Natürlich war es blauäugig.
Unbestritten.
- Aber ich denke, das gehört dazu.
* Motorbrummen *
Drei Länder, drei Auswanderungen.
Die Fortsetzung der Geschichten aus
Griechenland, Schweden und Kanada.
Das ist
"Auf und davon - Ein Jahr danach".
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Hättest du keinen Matsch gewollt,
hättest du hier durchgehen müssen.
Äh ...
Uah!
* Sie lacht. *
Papa hat den besseren Weg genommen.
Ich habe jetzt eine Pfütze im Schuh.
Ein Nachmittag im Frühsommer 2023.
Oh, ich sehe Hawaii.
Dort sieht es nach Sand aus.
(Kind) Eiskalt.
- Eiskalt.
Aber du gehst
nicht wirklich rein, oder?
Seit einem Jahr
lebt Familie Rotzler in Schweden.
Es hat 10 °C.
* Er lacht. *
Ich finde es einfach kühl.
* Sie lacht. *
Sie ist schon eine totale Schwedin.
Auch in Bezug auf die Sauna.
Nach der Schule gehen sie
nach dem Schwimmen in die Sauna.
Das findet sie super.
Oh, Liana, ist es nicht kalt?
Sabrina und Jonas
gaben in der Schweiz alles auf
und kauften eine Ferienanlage
mitten in der Natur.
Es reicht, Fiona.
Was machst du jetzt?
Für dich,
damit du nicht stehen musst.
Oh!
Hat die bald sechsköpfige Familie
ihren Platz im neuen Leben gefunden?
Und konnten sich Jonas und Sabrina
ihre Träume erfüllen?
Wir hatten keine Erfahrung in
der Hotellerie, in der Gastronomie
und im Tourismus.
Winter 2022: Familie Rotzler
ist auf Haussuche in Schweden.
Eigentlich haben sie alles,
was sie sich wünschen:
gutbezahlte Jobs, drei herzige Kinder
und ein Eigenheim.
Trotzdem zieht es sie weg.
Irgendwie empfanden wir immer
eine gewisse Unzufriedenheit.
Wir begannen, uns zu fragen, woher
sie kommt. Denn wir hatten ja alles.
Dann merkten wir,
dass wir etwas mehr Platz
und etwas mehr Freiheit brauchen.
Wir hinterfragten
auch das Arbeitsmodell.
Man arbeitet als Angestellter
und setzt sich Stress aus.
Man arbeitet nicht für sich selbst,
sondern für jemand anderen.
Man steckt seine ganze Energie
also nicht in etwas Eigenes.
Wir fragten uns, was wir
dagegen tun können und beschlossen,
unser Leben zu ändern.
Skal.
- Skal, välkommen.
Schnell haben sie sich
für ein Objekt entschieden.
Es ist total schön.
Sie übernehmen eine in die Jahre
gekommene Ferienanlage mit 60 Betten
mitten im Wald -
und mit ihr viel Arbeit.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Oh ja.
(Englisch)
Ich schätze, dass wir
die nächsten zwei bis drei Jahre
mit Aussortieren und Aufräumen
beschäftigt sein werden.
So ist das halt.
Ich schaue,
ob eine Sicherung durchgebrannt ist,
aber es sieht nicht danach aus.
Was ist das in der Ecke?
- Ah, deshalb stank es so.
Das ist irgendeine seltsame Ratte.
* Dynamische Musik *
Nur drei Wochen haben sie Zeit,
bis die ersten Gäste kommen.
Sie renovieren das Restaurant,
zusammen mit Nachbar Ulf.
Wenn man versucht, es perfekt
zu machen, wird man nie fertig.
Irgendwann wollen wir ja eröffnen.
Immer mit dabei: die drei Kinder.
Nicht aufs Bett!
- Aber es ist so warm.
Hello.
(Englisch)
Alle Teller rausnehmen.
Du kannst das.
Ab jetzt kocht Jonas
für zahlende Gäste.
So ...
(Englisch)
Immer wieder
kommen Altlasten zum Vorschein.
Man merkt,
dass es total vernachlässigt wurde.
Gästebetrieb und Kinderbetreuung
unter einen Hut zu bringen ...
* Klappern *
Äh ... Was machst du genau?
... ist
eine ständige Herausforderung.
Bist du noch müde?
Liana auch, so wie es aussieht.
Sie melden Kian und Liana
zur Vorschule an.
Das bringt ein wenig Entlastung.
Das ist einerseits
wegen der Sprache wichtig,
damit sie Schwedisch sprechen,
und andererseits gibt es hier
wenige Kinder in ihrem Alter.
Für Familie Rotzler
heisst das viel Autofahren:
fast 2 Std. pro Tag.
Das Gästegeschäft aber
läuft nur langsam an.
Neue Ideen sind gefragt:
Jonas reaktiviert die Langlaufloipe.
Wir brauchen die Skispuren,
um Leute ins Restaurant zu bringen.
Das Restaurant brauchen wir,
um Leute ins Hotel zu bringen.
All das benötigen wir am Ende,
um zu überleben.
Sie organisieren
einen Weihnachtsmarkt.
Mit dem Event
wollen sie die Ferienanlage
in der Region bekannter machen.
Es steckt noch ein Stück Arbeit
dahinter, damit es läuft
und damit wir in den nächsten Jahren
reich werden oder so.
Es ist
ein riesiges Potenzial vorhanden.
Man kann hier so viel machen.
Unsere Challenge ist es,
herauszufinden, was funktioniert.
Einerseits muss die Infrastruktur
unserer Anlage so gut sein,
damit wir es anbieten können,
und andererseits muss es
die Kundschaft auch annehmen.
Zurück in den Frühsommer 2023.
Noch ist Vorsaison in Schweden, aber
auf der Ferienanlage Skalsjögarden
tummeln sich bereits ein paar Gäste.
Wir haben eine Buchung von Gästen,
die gern den Hotpot benutzen würden.
Den Hotpot muss man ...
... 1 1/2 Std.
bevor man einfeuern kann, befüllen.
Dann dauert es etwa 4 Std.,
bis er warm ist.
Mit dabei: Kian und Liana.
Kaum drei Monate
gingen die beiden in die Vorschule.
Jetzt sind sie
wieder die ganze Zeit zu Hause.
Bleibt kurz sitzen.
Liana wehrte sich jeden Morgen
mit Händen und Füssen dagegen,
in die Vorschule zu gehen.
Als ein Kind,
das die Kultur nicht kennt
und die Sprache nicht versteht,
hätte sie
wohl Extrabetreuung gebraucht.
Wir fuhren also jeden Tag 100 km,
um unser Kind
an einen Ort zu bringen,
an dem es sich nicht wohlfühlte.
Ich will malen.
Willst du mir beim Malen zuschauen?
Das Problem ist: Wenn ich male,
kannst du nicht auch malen.
Dann kannst du einfach zuschauen.
Malen.
Ich schaue mal,
was sich machen lässt.
Im Restaurant kümmert sich Sabrina
derweil um neue Buchungen.
Wir haben am Wochenende
ein ziemlich volles Haus.
Ich bereite schon mal
alle Check-ins vor,
denn zurzeit weiss ich nicht, ob
ich am Wochenende hier sein werde.
Ich möchte, dass alles bereit ist.
Sabrina ist mittlerweile
im neunten Monat schwanger.
Ich merkte in den letzten Tagen,
dass ich
einen Gang zurückschalten muss.
Aber solange es mir gut geht,
kann ich arbeiten.
Ich kann nicht nur rumsitzen.
Das ist langweilig.
Es ist schön, so viele Check-ins
für die nächsten paar Tage zu haben.
Ein Teil der Gäste
kommt im Haus Marsens unter.
Dort hat Jonas über den Winter
eigenhändig acht Gästezimmer
renoviert und drei Bäder erneuert.
Jetzt fehlen
nur noch die Wände im Flur.
* Kian plappert unverständlich. *
Jetzt willst du schon nicht mehr.
Aber ich muss das kurz streichen.
Immer Kinder um sich herum zu haben,
macht es nicht unbedingt einfacher.
Aber es ist ein gutes Land,
um Kinder zu haben.
Ja.
- Und sie sind ...
Es geht nicht nur ums Finanzielle
oder Betreuungstechnische,
man ist auch
überall willkommen mit Kindern.
Niemand schaut einen schräg an,
wenn man mit vier Kindern
ins Restaurant geht.
Hat es geklappt?
- Ich muss noch weitermachen.
Du musst noch weitermachen?
Es dauert nicht lange.
- Hast du mitgeholfen?
Nein.
- Er will immer mithelfen.
Mit dem Hotpot hat er angefangen.
- (Frau) Dauert das so lange?
Ja, er muss das Wasser
2 Std. vorher einfüllen.
Wollt ihr ihn
vor oder nach dem Essen benutzen?
Jonas geniesst es, sich
den Tag selbst einteilen zu können.
Zuletzt war er Qualitätsmanager
in der Pharmalogistik.
In der Schweiz
stand ich permanent unter Druck.
Ich war gedanklich
immer schon eine Woche weiter:
Welche Audits und welche Meetings
haben wir noch?
Tack-tack-tack. Hier ein Termin
und dort dieses und jenes.
Das ist hier nicht so.
Meiner Meinung nach
ist die Lebensqualität viel höher.
Ah, jetzt kommt er, schön.
In 2 Std. ist der Hotpot
für die Gäste parat.
(Frau) Geht es dort oder da lang?
Warte, wir holen Jonas. Schatz?
Du bist besser in diesen Dingen.
Ich will nicht, dass sie
in die falsche Richtung gehen.
Man müsste ihn
noch ein bisschen nett herrichten.
Ja. Sie gehen nach dem Abendessen
rein. Sie essen Schnitzel.
Nach dem Abendessen?
Dann hätte ich ihn
nicht jetzt einheizen müssen.
Er ist bestimmt warm genug.
Du sagtest ... Egal.
- Ich sagte, ich wüsste es nicht.
Dann kann ich später
nochmals einheizen.
Kommst du?
- Ja.
Er kommt.
Das Gästegeschäft läuft nur, wenn
die beiden als Team funktionieren.
* Lautes Zirpen *
Melde dich,
wenn du einen Kopf siehst.
Auf dem griechischen Peloponnes
suchen Alain Aegerter und Anita Thomi
ihre Schnappschildkröten.
Halte den Stiel doch mal dort rein,
wo sie so gern essen,
und bewege ihn vorsichtig.
Den Stiel, nicht das Netz.
Jetzt sieht man wieder Blasen.
Jetzt sind sie dort hinten.
Wenn du ewig
mit diesem Ding rumfuchtelst,
wird es nicht besser.
Sie sehen dich.
Hier ist eine, schau.
Sehr cool.
Die Tiere wollen sie
in einen grösseren Teich zügeln.
Seit fast zwei Jahren leben
die beiden mit ihren Schildkröten
und Giftschlangen in Griechenland.
Ihre Idee: Bungalows bauen und
Ferien für Reptilienfreunde anbieten.
Wenn du willst,
darfst du ihn rauslassen.
So.
Es ist schön,
wenn sie nicht mehr umziehen müssen,
und in ihrem grossen Becken sind.
Ich dachte: "Wo ist die Maus?"
* Anita lacht. *
Von ihrem Ziel aber
sind sie noch weit entfernt.
Trotz Baustelle steht
noch immer kein einziger Bungalow.
Denn das Schicksal
hatte einen ganz anderen Plan.
Alles begann im Sommer 2021.
Nichts deutet darauf hin,
welches Drama sie bald erwartet.
Das Bett aufzustellen,
ist das Zeichen,
dass wir wirklich hierbleiben.
Genau.
Keine drei Wochen nach ihrer Ankunft
auf dem griechischen Peloponnes
wütet ein verheerender Waldbrand.
Dort hinten
sahen wir zuerst nur Rauch.
Plötzlich kam das Feuer über den
Berg und man sah oben alles brennen.
Als das Feuer ausbricht,
ist Alain in der Schweiz,
Anita
mit ihren Schwiegereltern allein.
Es kam rasend schnell näher.
Wir waren vom Feuer umzingelt.
Ich dachte: "Jetzt sterbe ich.
Das war's jetzt."
"Nun verbrenne ich mit meinen
Schwiegereltern in diesem Auto."
* Melancholische Klänge *
Anita gelingt die Flucht -
mithilfe eines Freundes.
Die Flammen jedoch
vernichten fast sämtliches
Hab und Gut der Auswanderer -
und ihr Wohnhaus.
Glück im Unglück:
Ihre Schildkröten und Schlangen
sind aufgrund fehlender Papiere
noch in der Schweiz.
Eine Versicherung hatten
die beiden noch nicht abgeschlossen.
Makler Georgios, der ihnen
das Haus vermittelte, beruhigt.
Der griechische Staat
übernimmt 80 % der Kosten,
um ein neues Haus zu bauen.
Das glaube ich erst, wenn es klappt.
Aber es klingt
natürlich interessant.
Doch, das stimmt. Das sagte
der Präsident höchstpersönlich.
Als es mal kleine Brände
in Olivenhainen usw. gab,
wurde immer bezahlt.
Wir hoffen,
dass alles wieder gut wird.
* Nachdenkliche Klänge *
Im Haus eines Freundes
kommen sie unter.
Zum Wohl.
- Prost.
Holländer Hans - vor vielen Jahren
ebenfalls ausgewandert -
lässt sie
in seiner Einliegerwohnung wohnen.
Zusammen mit ihren Reptilien,
die Alain mittlerweile
aus der Schweiz geholt hat.
(Liebevoll) So.
Etwas Frisches.
Weitermachen oder aufgeben?
Gemeinsam entscheiden sie,
sie wollen bleiben
und an ihrem Traum festhalten -
Schicksalsschlag hin oder her.
Es nervt mich schon.
Das ist unbestritten.
Aber ich will hier
nicht mein halbes Leben
mit Jammern und Leiden verbringen.
Trotz der Abbrucharbeiten
empfangen sie eine erste Reisegruppe.
Salü, Rolf.
- Geht es dir gut?
Ja, tipptopp.
Wir freuten uns sehr auf euch
und hoffen,
dass wir viele Schildkröten finden.
Sie sind jeweils hier
oder dort hinten.
Ein Jahr nach dem Brand könnten sie
mit dem Wiederaufbau starten,
doch noch
fehlt das Okay der Behörden.
Sie ziehen in die Garage,
die vom Feuer verschont wurde.
Schlafen, wohnen und arbeiten
auf knapp 20 m2.
Ganz am Anfang dachten wir,
dass wir in einem halben Jahr
wieder oben wohnen werden.
Viele Leute schmunzelten
und meinten,
es würde bestimmt
ein bis drei Jahre dauern,
bis wir wieder dort wohnen können.
Da es auch bei den Behörden länger
dauerte, als wir gedacht hatten,
waren wir manchmal
schon etwas verzweifelt
und die Stimmung
war nicht immer toll.
Auf eigene Kosten
beginnen sie mit dem Wiederaufbau.
* Leichte, mediterrane Klänge *
Nach acht Monaten Bauzeit ist das
Haus im Frühsommer 2023 fast fertig.
Wir waren einen Winter hier
und hatten alles, was wir brauchten.
Wir hatten eine Heizung
für ganz kalte Tage.
Es war einfach unser Zuhause.
Das ist wirklich
ein wunderbares Gefühl -
auch wenn es die Garage war.
Beim Bau machen sie vieles selbst.
Das spart Geld.
Als gelernter Elektriker
kümmert sich Alain
um die Stromanschlüsse in der Küche.
Wird es gut?
- Ja, ja.
Was ist das jetzt?
Das Aussenlicht.
- Welche ist für den Backofen?
Die gibt es noch nicht.
- Man muss sie noch einziehen, was?
Ja.
- Gut.
Es braucht noch etwas Zeit.
- Ich teste mal kurz die Lampe.
Die beiden können es kaum erwarten,
endlich hier oben zu schlafen.
Das wird unser Bett,
für jeden von uns
eine 1,60 m breite Matratze.
Im heissen Sommer
haben wir viel Platz
und im Winter, wenn es kalt ist,
können wir zusammenrücken
und einander wärmen.
Wir können es
noch fast nicht glauben,
dass jetzt hier
wieder ein Haus steht.
Der Sommer
wird natürlich viel schöner,
wenn wir uns hier
etwas ausbreiten können
und nicht auf 3,5 m2 Schatten
beschränkt sind
wie im letzten Sommer.
So.
Finger weg.
- Ja.
So. Das sollte reichen.
Die Baukosten:
umgerechnet rund 120'000 Fr.
Einen Teil davon konnten Alain
und Anita mit Spenden finanzieren,
die sie von Freunden erhalten haben.
Der Rest ist Geld,
das sie für den Bau der Ferienhäuser
vorgesehen hatten.
Doch was ist mit dem versprochenen
Geld vom griechischen Staat?
Bezüglich Subventionen
sieht es folgendermassen aus:
Wir haben ein Schreiben erhalten,
in dem steht,
dass die Subventionen
gesprochen wurden.
Wir haben
unsere Kontodaten angegeben ...
... und hoffen, dass tatsächlich mal
etwas auf unseren Konten eintrifft.
Aber wir kennen viele Leute -
auch Griechen -
denen Geld versprochen wurde.
Obwohl es bei diesen Leuten
viel mehr um die Existenz geht
als bei uns,
haben sie
bis heute noch nichts erhalten.
Ohne Subventionen keine Ferienhäuser.
Und ohne Ferienhäuser fehlen
ihnen Einnahmen - ein Teufelskreis.
* Möwenschreie *
Ein luxuriöses Gästehaus
direkt am Meer in Kanada.
Für diesen Traum haben Thomas Range
und seine Partnerin
Barbara Hasenböhler alles investiert,
was sie besassen.
Nach einer turbulenten Bauzeit
glaubten sie,
das Schlimmste hinter sich zu haben.
Doch weit gefehlt.
Komm, Trulla. Cookie!
- Komm, wir gehen an den Strand.
Ein Hurrikan hat ihr Leben
aufs Neue durcheinandergewirbelt.
Um an ihren Hausstrand zu kommen,
müssen sie seit dem Sturm
einen grossen Umweg machen.
Aber es sieht gut aus,
was sie machen, nicht?
Sicher besser als vorher.
Ihre Strandtreppe
wurde durch den Hurrikan zerstört
und auch die Uferbefestigung
beschädigt.
Hey, sir.
Mit unvorstellbarer Wucht traf
Fiona im Herbst 2022 auf die Küste.
Das Wasser riss
die zentnerschweren Betonblöcke,
die zum Schutz des Ufers aufgestapelt
waren, einfach weg.
Als es wieder heller wurde,
sahen wir,
dass das Meer die Kante
unseres Grundstücks erreicht hatte.
All das hier war mit Wasser gefüllt.
Wir hatten eine Springflut,
die zwischen 12 und 16 m hoch war.
Es war einer der stärksten Stürme
in der Geschichte der Insel.
Der Hurrikan begann am Nachmittag
und wütete eine ganze Nacht.
Es wurde
von Stunde zu Stunde krasser.
Ziemlich genau um 21 Uhr sagte ich:
"Thomas, wollen wir nicht gehen?"
Ich sagte: "Nein, wir bleiben hier."
"Wo sollen wir jetzt hin?
Es ist doch gefährlich draussen."
"Es wird nicht besser,
wenn wir irgendwo hinfahren."
Wir hatten das Gefühl,
dass es überall knackte und krachte.
Aber wir sahen draussen ja nichts,
weil es stockdunkel war.
Das ist
ein total unangenehmes Gefühl.
Man weiss,
dass es von irgendwoher kommt,
aber man sieht es nicht.
Und dieser Lärm!
Es war, als würde man
mit einem Auto 240 km/h fahren
und dabei die Scheiben unten lassen.
So laut war der Wind.
Zusätzlich zum Windlärm
kam noch der Wasserlärm.
Ihnen bleibt nichts anderes übrig,
als allein im Haus auszuharren.
Um 2 Uhr in der Nacht hört Thomas
ein Krachen im oberen Stock
und schaut in der Tower Suite nach.
Ich hatte
nur das Handy als Lichtquelle,
aber ich sah bereits,
dass hier am Boden alles nass war.
Ich leuchtete ein bisschen herum
und merkte,
dass ganz viel Wasser am Boden
und das Fenster aufgesprungen war.
Es war nur noch an zwei Orten
in der Verankerung befestigt
und hier drückte das Wasser herein.
Dann drückten wir mit aller Gewalt -
gegen den Wind und gegen den Regen -
ein Holzbrett vors Fenster.
Wir schafften es irgendwie,
an vier Orten Schrauben reinzudrehen
und das Brett zu fixieren,
damit wir das Ganze wenigstens
etwas unterbrechen konnten.
Es ging
gar nicht mehr um unser Leben.
Wir wussten,
dass unser Leben nicht bedroht ist
bzw. wir hatten inzwischen
ein gutes Gefühl, was das betrifft.
Aber wir hatten keine Ahnung,
wie gross der Schaden am Hotel ist.
Hurrikan Fiona reiht sich ein
in eine lange Liste von Problemen,
die Barbara und Thomas während
ihrer Auswanderung erlebt haben.
Schauen wir noch einmal
zwei Jahre zurück, wie alles begann.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Barbara und Thomas
sind noch nicht einmal abgereist
und stecken bereits
in Schwierigkeiten.
Die beiden Gastro-Profis waren
schon auf dem Sprung nach Kanada,
als das Land pandemiebedingt
die Grenzen dicht macht
und sie nicht mehr einreisen lässt.
Ich bin eine Person -
das ist nicht unbedingt gut -,
die einfach nicht aufgeben will.
Aufgeben ist für mich ein Wort,
das es eigentlich gar nicht gibt.
Als sie nach 14 langen Monaten
endlich auf Prince Edward Island
ankommen, ist die Freude gross.
So schön, so schön.
Die riesige Villa im Hampton-Style
wollen sie
in ein exklusives Gästehaus
mit sieben Zimmern und Suiten
umbauen.
Hier ist das eine Zimmer.
Hier ist alles offen
und man sieht die ganze Meeresfront.
Aus Garagen
sollen Gästezimmer werden.
Bis ins Detail
hat Barbara alles geplant.
Die Baubewilligung aber
lässt auf sich warten.
Juli und August sind die Monate,
in denen man Umsatz macht.
Wenn wir im Juli und im August
nicht geöffnet haben,
haben wir ganz klar
ein finanzielles Problem.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Gerade noch rechtzeitig
können sie mit dem Umbau beginnen.
Das ganze Haus
ist eine einzige Baustelle -
trotz eisiger Temperaturen.
Durch die Pandemie
sind die Preise gestiegen.
Alles ist plötzlich viel teurer, als
Barbara und Thomas budgetiert haben:
Öl, Strom und auch das Baumaterial.
Es tauchten viele Kosten auf, mit
denen wir nicht gerechnet hatten.
Wir hoffen nun einfach,
dass die Leute willig sind,
vielleicht 20 Dollar mehr pro Nacht
zu bezahlen.
Geenie, kommst du auch noch?
Sie verkaufen
ihre Eigentumswohnung in der Schweiz
und nehmen
einen zusätzlichen Kredit auf.
Alles scheint auf gutem Weg zu sein,
bis Barbara einen Unfall hat.
Sie bricht sich wenige Wochen vor
der geplanten Eröffnung den Knöchel.
Ich musste operiert werden und
nun sind Platten und Schrauben drin.
Do you want to put that
under the board over there?
Thomas muss einspringen und anstelle
von Barbara die Baustelle managen.
Bin ich happy in dieser Situation?
Nein.
Die Zeit bis zur Eröffnung
wird immer knapper.
Und das Wichtigste fehlt immer noch:
die Möbel.
Sie hängen im Zoll in Halifax fest.
Bei Barbara und Thomas
liegen die Nerven blank.
Es beeinflusst unsere Stimmung
und unseren Umgang miteinander.
Man muss sich wirklich fragen:
Warum um alles in der Welt
tun wir uns das eigentlich an?
Ist es das wirklich wert?
Als die Möbel endlich da sind,
bleiben ihnen weniger als 48 Std.
bis zur Eröffnung.
Voilà.
Yes, we did it!
So.
Der alles entscheidende Faktor.
Um die Gäste zu begeistern,
ist mindestens eine davon nötig.
Ein knappes Jahr
nach ihrer Ankunft in Kanada
können Barbara und Thomas
ihre ersten Gäste begrüssen.
I guess so, right?
- (Mann) Yeah.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Da alles so eng war,
konnten wir nie einen Tag ausspannen
und uns mental darauf vorbereiten.
Aus heutiger Sicht
muss man leider sagen,
dass es diese Phase
auch danach nie gab.
Nein.
Immer wenn wir Zeit
für uns geplant hatten,
damit wir hätten ausspannen können,
gab es wieder irgendeinen Super-GAU.
Ja.
Die Auswanderer in Schweden blieben
zwar von Naturkatastrophen verschont,
Zeit zum Ausspannen
fehlt aber auch hier.
Die Gäste wollen verpflegt werden.
Das Frühstück machen wir.
Eigentlich wäre Sabrina dran,
aber sie schlief nochmals ein.
Familie Rotzler
kümmert sich um das Frühstück.
Für Mittag- und Abendessen
haben sie eine Köchin engagiert.
Auch bei der Kinderbetreuung
haben sie jetzt Unterstützung.
Seit ein paar Tagen
ist Volontärin Lena da.
Runtersteigen?
Achtung, pass auf Liana auf.
Lena bekommt freie Kost und Logis.
Dafür hilft sie mit.
Vier Wochen
will sie bei Rotzlers bleiben.
Gut so?
Bis zu den Betriebsferien im Oktober
haben wir immer Leute hier.
Es ist super,
wenn sie Schweizerdeutsch sprechen.
Dann können sie sich
um die Kinder kümmern.
Das ist besser,
als wenn wir nur zu zweit sind.
Jonas und Sabrina müssen das Geschäft
mit den Gästen weiter ankurbeln.
Noch reicht der Ertrag
der Ferienanlage nicht zum Leben.
Deshalb wollen sie
die Anlage attraktiver machen.
Ihre neue Idee:
Stellplätze für Wohnmobile.
Heute will Jonas
mehrere Sockel betonieren.
Das mit den Stellplätzen
hatten wir auf dem Schirm,
aber wir wollten
nicht voll darauf setzen.
Wir merkten jedoch relativ schnell,
dass extrem viele Leute mit Wohn-
mobilen im Norden unterwegs sind.
Deshalb entschieden wir uns,
fünf schöne Stellplätze zu bauen.
Schon jetzt fahren
immer wieder Camper auf den Hof.
Was ist denn da los?
Das sind Schweden.
Die Ferienanlage scheint
ein beliebter Stopp zu sein.
Aber nicht alle,
die anhalten, wollen bleiben.
Ich habe grundsätzlich
nichts dagegen,
wenn jemand auf meinem Parkplatz
eine Pause macht,
aber wenn man
beim Blick aus dem Fenster
regelmässig Gäste ankommen und dann
im Gebüsch verschwinden sieht,
wo sie ihr Geschäft machen ...
Die können
in ihren eigenen Garten scheissen
und müssen dafür
nicht zu mir kommen.
Für die, die übernachten wollen,
gibt es bald Grillstelle
und Stromanschluss.
Uh-hu.
Als gelernter Polymechaniker
kann Jonas vieles selber machen.
Mal sehen ...
Klebt er unten fest? Hm!
Allein kommt er
aber nur langsam vorwärts.
Man kann die Neigung
nicht so gut einstellen.
Jetzt klappt's.
Da ist jegliche Hilfe willkommen.
Aber pass auf,
dass du keinen Stromschlag kriegst.
So, das sieht noch aus
wie vor einem Jahr.
* Sie lacht. *
Oder noch schlimmer.
Äh ... Hier.
Das sind die Kabel,
um die Lampen zu befestigen.
Super.
Kontrollier zuerst,
ob der Stecker derselbe ist.
Es gibt neue und alte.
Lena soll das Ferienhaus Brinka
fertig einrichten.
Hier hatte Familie Rotzler
das erste halbe Jahr gewohnt.
Jetzt wollen sie das Haus
an Gäste vermieten.
So.
Du kannst alle zusammenbauen.
Du kannst es selbstständig
nach Gutdünken einrichten.
Ja.- Ich bin diesbezüglich
ziemlich offen.
* Sabrina keucht. *
Ich muss mich kurz hinsetzen.
Ich bin bereits ausser Puste.
So sieht es am Ende aus.
- Ja.
Im Juni ist es sehr lange hell und
man benötigt überall noch Rollos.
Letztes Jahr
improvisierten wir ein bisschen
und stellten z.B.
eine Matratze vors Fenster,
aber für die Gäste
möchte ich Rollos.
Auch die Nachttischchen fehlen noch.
Wir müssen sie noch montieren.
Und die Kabel.
- Und die kleinen Lampen.
Nach und nach bringt Familie Rotzler
die Ferienanlage wieder in Schuss.
Das sieht nicht schlecht aus.
Es hält.
Für den schwedischen Wald reicht es.
Und der nächste.
Ich hatte mir gewünscht ...
... dass wir
vieles gemeinsam machen können.
Aufgrund der Situation
nach dem Brand
und wegen unserer
unterschiedlichen Art und Weise,
solche Dinge zu verarbeiten,
war es auch für unsere Beziehung
eine grosse Herausforderung.
Wir dachten beide
wohl zwei- bis dreimal:
"Brauche ich
die Person neben mir zum Leben?"
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Es zeichnet Anita und Alain aus,
dass sie diese Krise
gemeinsam überstanden haben.
Die Hürden aber bleiben gross.
Ginge es nach Alain,
würde er jetzt Ferienhäuser bauen.
Aber ohne die Subventionen
sind ihnen die Hände gebunden.
Riech mal.
Anita will sich
nicht entmutigen lassen.
Du bist ein Angsthase.
Dann gehen wir zum Napf.
Vor vier Tagen stand plötzlich
ein junger Kater vor unserem Haus.
Sie geniesst die kleinen Dinge, die
ihr das Leben in Griechenland bietet.
Das Einzige, was in Bezug auf diese
Katze problematisch sein könnte,
ist die Tatsache, dass ich sie
mit Alains Wurst füttere.
Komm, puss, puss.
Alain hat für den jungen Kater keine
Augen. Er hat andere Prioritäten.
Das hohe Gras muss weg, denn es steht
wieder ein heisser Sommer bevor.
Trockenes Gras brennt wie Zunder
und gefährdet das Haus.
Waldbrände sind v.a. im Hochsommer
ein grosses Risiko.
Wir mussten uns wirklich überlegen,
ob wir mit dieser Gefahr,
die immer besteht -
hier brennt es jedes Jahr -
leben können.
Können wir uns
nach dieser Gefahr richten
und uns entsprechend verhalten?
Wir sagten beide:
"Ja, das können wir."
Deshalb sind wir noch hier.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Für Anita und Alain ist klar:
Sie wollen in Griechenland bleiben.
Hier fühlen sie sich wohl.
Nicht zuletzt wegen der Menschen,
die hier leben.
Hallo, Hans.
- Wie geht's?- Gut.
Holländer Hans war einer der ersten,
den sie in Griechenland
kennengelernt haben.
Die Beziehung zu ihm
ist eine besondere.
Bei Hans fanden sie
nach dem Feuer Unterschlupf.
Und er war es, der Anita
und ihren Schwiegereltern
den Weg aus dem Flammenmeer
gezeigt hatte.
Die Erinnerung an die Flucht mit dem
Auto ist bei Hans noch immer präsent.
Wir mussten raus
und durch das Feuer hindurch.
Das dauerte mit dem Auto
schätzungsweise 10 Min.
Das ist ziemlich lang.
Sie wussten nicht,
wie die Strasse verläuft.
Es sind geschotterte Landstrassen
mit Abzweigungen.
Man muss den Verlauf kennen.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich ihnen das Leben rettete.
So, wie ich Anita kenne,
hätte sie auf Nebenstrassen
nicht rausgefunden.
Unter Stress hätte ich das
wohl auch nicht geschafft.
Daher denke ich sehr wohl,
dass er Anitas und das Leben
meiner Eltern gerettet hat.
In Extremsituationen
kann ich handeln.
Bei mir kommt die Angst
erst danach. Dann hilft Ouzo.
Also, gut, vielen Dank.
- Tschau.
Tschüss.
* Beschwingte Klänge *
Willst du dir noch Schuhe anziehen?
- Nein.
"Nein, keine Schuhe."
- Hier ist ja alles betoniert.
Ein Jahr und neun Monate
nach dem Brand
können sie das erste Mal
wieder in ihrem Haus schlafen.
Im eigenen Bett, das sie
nach ihren Wünschen gestaltet haben.
Aegi?
- Ja?
Du musst die Matratze
selbst beziehen.- Wieso?
Ich bin bereits erschöpft.
Machst du Scherze?
Soll ich in Koroni für morgen früh
etwas Leckeres holen?
Schau dir das an.
Damit wir nach einer erfolgreichen
Nacht im Haus schlemmen können?
Ja, das ist gut.
- Ist das eine Idee?- Mhm.
* Kuss *
Ich glaube, weil ich mich hier
per se viel wohler fühle
als in der Schweiz,
kann ich viel mehr ...
... wegstecken.
Jetzt sind wir so weit gekommen,
dass es alles andere als clever
wäre, nun aufzugeben.
V.a. wäre die ganze Mühe,
der ganze Aufwand,
den wir betrieben haben,
und all die Emotionen - der
körperliche und seelische Stress -
umsonst gewesen.
Dazu war ich
definitiv noch nicht bereit.
* Rockige Klänge *
Zum Aufgeben hätten Barbara
und Thomas eigentlich allen Grund.
Als Hurrikan Fiona
über Prince Edward Island zieht,
hinterlässt er
eine Spur der Verwüstung.
Auch das 45 Steps Inn ist betroffen.
Die Schäden sind zwar kaum sichtbar,
nach der Untersuchung
des Versicherungsgutachters
aber umso gravierender.
* Lautes Hämmern *
Das ist ein typisches Beispiel:
Wir haben festgestellt,
dass im gesamten unteren Bereich
alle Wände innen feucht sind.
Das Fenster
muss komplett ersetzt werden -
und nicht nur das,
sondern alle Fenster
im Bereich Restaurant und Küche
und in der Tower Suite sowieso.
Das sind insgesamt etwa 60 Fenster.
Kostenpunkt:
500'000 kanadische Dollar ...
Hi.
- ... rund 320'000 Fr.
Kein halbes Jahr nach der Eröffnung
ist das Gästehaus
wieder eine Baustelle.
In der Tower Suite mussten sie
den Boden und die Isolation ersetzen,
alles neu streichen
sowie die Bettkonstruktion erneuern.
Das nimmt definitiv Schwung raus.
Es ist ja so, dass ich Bau...
Wer liebt Baustellen? Niemand.
Es ist schon ermüdend.
Ich befinde mich
immer wieder in Situationen,
in denen ich mir sage:
"Es muss nicht
zu 100 % perfekt sein."
Man drückt öfter ein Auge zu
als auch schon.
Der Austausch von 60 Fenstern
dauert mehrere Wochen
und kann nur ausserhalb der Saison
gemacht werden.
Zu gross wäre der Einnahmeausfall.
Deshalb wurden die Risse in den
Fenstern nur provisorisch repariert.
Das ist nur ein quick fix,
nicht die Lösung.
Es hält nur leichten Regen ab.
Sobald es richtig stürmt
und quer regnet,
sind sie wieder undicht.
Schön, nicht wahr?
- Ja.
Weisst du, wo die Lampen sind,
die ich kaufte?
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
- Glühbirnen?- Ja.
Du weisst es nicht, was?
Ich hole sie.
80 % der Schadenssumme
übernimmt die Versicherung.
Den Rest müssen
Barbara und Thomas selber tragen.
45 Min. Fahrt
sind es vom Skalsjögarden
bis in die nächste Stadt.
Und tschüss.
- Tschüss.
In Bollnäs hat Sabrina einen Termin.
Sie muss
zur Schwangerschaftskontrolle.
(Frau) Sabrina?
- Ja.
(Schwedisch)
Die regelmässige Untersuchung
findet bei einer Hebamme statt.
Einen Frauenarzt hat Sabrina
seit Beginn der Schwangerschaft
noch nicht gesehen -
nichts Ungewöhnliches in Schweden.
* Schnelles Pochen *
* Sabrina atmet tief. *
Ich spreche mit allen, mit denen
es möglich ist, schwedisch.
Meine Grammatik ist vielleicht
nicht immer zu 100 % korrekt,
aber die Menschen schätzen es sehr,
wenn man ihre Sprache spricht -
egal ob Hebamme,
Kinderkrankenschwester
oder Lehrerin.
Einige Leute, mit denen ich
regelmässig schwedisch spreche,
geben sich Mühe,
und dann klappt es super.
Es gibt aber auch Leute,
die sich keine Mühe geben.
Dann verstehe ich teils echt wenig.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen -
insbesondere geschäftlich,
mit den Gästen -
klappt es ganz gut.
Hej da.
- Hej da.
Hello.
- Grüezi.
Wie war es?
- Alles gut.
* Nachrichtenton *
Wir sind willkommen,
die Einkäufe abzuholen.
Du kannst mir die Bonbons geben.
* Leichte, verspielte Musik *
Bis zum errechneten Geburtstermin
sind es nur noch ein paar Tage.
Drei, fünf, sechs, sieben, acht.
Kein Grund für Sabrina und Jonas,
nervös zu werden.
Wie viel haben wir noch?
- Das und die Acht.
Es ist noch
ein bisschen eine Baustelle.
In Griechenland
haben Alain und Anita Besuch -
nicht von Freunden oder Verwandten.
Eine Gruppe Touristen hat spontan
eine Tiergartenführung gebucht.
Hier unten ist noch
unser Breitrand-Weibchen.
Sie ist viel hier,
auch wenn Halbschatten herrscht.
(Frau) Dieser Panzer
ist etwas Besonderes.- Mhm.
Zbindi hat sich dort
unter dem verbrannten Olivenbaum
eine Höhle gebaut.
Das ist
sein absoluter Lieblingsplatz.
Er hat noch geschlafen.
Die Welt der Reptilien
wollen sie ihren Gästen näherbringen.
So ihre Geschäftsidee.
Ein paar Erlebniswochen
mit Reisegruppen
konnten sie bereits durchführen
und auch einzelne Tagesausflüge.
Die haben kein Problem hier,
nicht wahr?- Nein.
Das ist ein ideales Klima für sie.
Wenn nur ab und zu mal
eine Reisegruppe kommt,
können wir definitiv
nicht davon leben.
Das ist nicht möglich.
Aber wegen des Baus hätten wir
zurzeit auch nicht mehr Platz.
Es bringt ja nichts, sich auf
die Reisegruppen zu konzentrieren,
und die Arbeiten
einem Handwerker zu überlassen,
mit dem man
vielleicht unzufrieden ist.
Das Ganze ist eine Güterabwägung.
Okay. Es hat mich sehr gefreut.
Vielen Dank,
dass wir kommen durften.
Ja, schön, dass ihr hier wart.
Tschüss, danke.
Geht das?
- Mhm.
Sobald ihr Wohnhaus fertig ist,
wollen sie Werbung machen
und mehr Reisen anbieten.
Es ist warm, was?
- Ja, es ist heiss.
Nur - um wirklich
vom Tourismus leben zu können,
müssten sie Ferienhäuser bauen
und vermieten.
Ein Teil der Möbel für
die Ferienhäuser steht schon bereit.
Doch noch immer ist kein Baubeginn
in Sicht - im Gegenteil.
In Sachen Bungalows erhielten sie vor
Kurzem eine weitere Hiobsbotschaft.
Wir wollen die Bungalows
immer noch bauen,
aber die Behörden machten uns gerade
einen Strich durch die Rechnung.
Zurzeit ist ein Gesetz
in der Vernehmlassung
und deshalb ist es
den Behörden untersagt,
Baubewilligungen für Grundstücke
zu unterschreiben,
die nicht an eine Strasse grenzen,
die bereits 1923 bestand.
Dieses Grundstück
grenzt ja nicht an eine Strasse.
Es grenzt an unser Grundstück
und an einen Feldweg.
Wir hatten eine Schreckwoche
bzw. einen Schreckmonat.
In dieser Zeit
waren wir schon etwas verzweifelt.
Dann sagten wir uns, dass wir das
jetzt einfach so annehmen müssen.
Uns bleibt nichts anderes übrig.
Es ist auch wichtig, den Kopf
für neue Ideen freizubekommen.
Irgendwann im Sommer muss dieses
Gesetz entweder aufgehoben sein,
damit wir
mit dem Bau beginnen können,
oder wir müssen umdenken.
Wir können die nächste Saison
nicht wieder verpassen
und darauf hoffen, dass wir
dann Bungalows bauen können.
Aber wie immer
wird sich ein Weg finden.
Es wird sich eine Tür öffnen.
So war es in unserem Leben immer.
Eigentlich unglaublich -
die Situation mit den Ferienhäusern
wird immer verzwickter.
Wir sind hier durch unser Business
und die Menschen auch fremdbestimmt,
aber ich habe immer noch das Gefühl,
dass ich mehr selbst bestimmen kann
als in der Schweiz,
als ich mich
in diesem blöden Hamsterrad befand.
Hier bin ich auch in einem
Hamsterrad, aber es ist anders.
Seit 2 Std.
ist Barbara bereits auf den Beinen.
Es ist kurz nach 8 Uhr:
Frühstückszeit im 45 Steps Inn.
(Barbara)
How are you?
- Good, and you?
Mehr als ein Dutzend Gäste
wollen verwöhnt werden.
350 kanadische Dollar -
umgerechnet 225 Fr. -
kostet das günstigste Zimmer mit
Frühstück während der Hauptsaison.
Good coffee.
- Thank you.
* Sanfte Musik *
Es ist Sommer
auf Prince Edward Island.
Zwei Monate sind
seit den Reparaturarbeiten vergangen.
Kaum noch etwas
erinnert an den Sturm,
der hier im letzten Herbst wütete.
* Sanfte Musik *
(Barbara)
(Frau) Yes.
So, ähm ...
Okay.
(Frau)
Hm!
Yes.
Bye.
In 99,9 % der Zeit
mache ich es total gern.
Aber manchmal bzw. ganz selten ...
... wäre ich lieber in meinem Zimmer
und hätte meine Ruhe.
Aber das geht halt nicht. Im
Hotel-Business muss man einfach ...
You need to glow.
Also, Range: die Zimmer heute.
David kommt in die Tower Suite ...
- Ja.
... und die Zwei reist ab.
That's it. Du musst
die Tower Suite und die Zwei machen.
Jeffrey kommt nur mit zwei Personen.
Die sieben Zimmer
sind so gut wie ausgebucht.
Seit der Eröffnung vor einem Jahr
hatten Thomas und Barbara
kaum einen Tag frei.
Jetzt kommen wir wieder
zum sportlichen Teil.
D.h., ich muss runter
in unser Kellerabteil
und saubere Bettwäsche holen.
Das muss man für dieses Zimmer
wohl sechs- oder siebenmal machen,
bis es wieder bezugsbereit ist.
* Dynamische Klänge *
In der Küche beginnt Barbara
bereits mit den Vorbereitungen
für das Abendessen.
Ihren Gästen
serviert sie ein dreigängiges Menü.
Thomas wirkt v.a. im Hintergrund.
Er ist für die Reinigung der Zimmer
und die Wäsche zuständig.
Ich würde das nicht
von 8 bis 20 Uhr machen wollen.
Es beschränkt sich ja wirklich
auf die Zeit
zwischen dem späten Vormittag
und dem frühen Nachmittag,
also 4-5 Std.
Aber die sind schon sehr intensiv.
Thomas, ist es für dich okay,
wenn ich mich
für eine Stunde hinlege?- Yes.
Gute Nacht.
- Gute Nacht.
Eine Stunde?
- Ja, Zimmerstunde.
Es heisst nicht Zimmerhalbestunde,
sondern Zimmerstunde.
Bei dir sind es immer Stunden.
Pah!
- Es sind immer mindestens zwei.
See you at four.
- Ja, ja, alles gut.
Der Tag ist bei den beiden
durchgetaktet:
Thomas schläft morgens etwas länger,
Barbara legt sich dafür
am Nachmittag hin.
* Ruhige Musik *
Was ich hier am liebsten mache?
Den Abendservice, würde ich sagen.
Gemütlich den Tisch einzudecken,
mit den Gästen
etwas Konversation zu betreiben
und ihnen
einen guten Wein zu empfehlen,
macht mir natürlich viel mehr Spass.
Hi.
Alles hängt an Barbara und Thomas -
als Gastgeber müssen sie
immer für ihre Gäste da sein.
(Barbara)
Es wäre schön, Mitarbeiter zu haben,
auf die wir uns
total verlassen können.
Das würde für uns vielleicht
einen freien Tag bedeuten.
So weit würde ich gar nicht gehen.
Ein Abend
wäre schon ein riesiger ...
Genau.
... Benefit.
- Genau.
Wenn jemand hier wäre, der sich um
das Haus und das Inn kümmern würde
und an den sich die Gäste
bei Problemen wenden könnten,
könnten wir abends
mal miteinander essen gehen
oder die Hunde schnappen
und an den Strand gehen.
Ja.
Alles klar.
Dann können wir euch
gleich einchecken. Das ist super.
Bei Familie Rotzler ist es
heute trotz Hochsaison eher ruhig.
Ich spüre es:
Die Sonne kommt bald wieder.
Der Grund:
Es ist regnerisch und kühl.
Die neuen Stellplätze finden
bei den Campern trotzdem Anklang.
Der ruhige Tag
kommt Sabrina nicht ungelegen.
Oh, Hund!
Töchterchen Malina
fordert ihre ganze Aufmerksamkeit.
Vor sechs Wochen kam sie
im Spital in Falun zur Welt.
Machen wir dich frisch?
* Malina quengelt. *
(Beruhigend) Ja.
Es ging alles gut.
Ich rief um etwa 3 Uhr morgens an
und sorgte dafür, dass sich
jemand um die Kinder kümmerte.
Und dann ...
Ja, ja, warte.
Um etwa 5 Uhr
waren wir in Falun im Spital
und um 17 Uhr war sie da.
Wir hatten relativ viel Zeit.
Nicht wahr?
Ja.
Willst du trinken?
* Malina weint. *
Ja, deutlicher
kann man es nicht sagen.
Das war bisher eigentlich die
problemloseste Schwangerschaft.
Ich weiss nicht, ob es daran lag,
dass wir uns alles selbst einteilen
und mehr selbst bestimmen können
und dass Jonas mehr da ist.
Es war sehr problemlos.
So, besser, nicht wahr?
(Flüsternd) So.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Und dann kommt sie tatsächlich: die
Sonne. Und mit ihr die Tagesgäste.
Schatz,
kommst du nachher kurz runter?
Es sind ziemlich viele Gäste da. Wir
müssen bei den Bestellungen helfen.
(Englisch)
I put it here.
Köchin Emma muss sich sputen.
Sechs Tage in der Woche
ist sie mit ihrer Familie
während der Sommersaison für das
leibliche Wohl der Gäste zuständig.
Cordon bleu und Wiener Schnitzel
sind die Verkaufsschlager.
Sabrina.
- Ja.
Kannst du dich um das hier
kümmern? Ich helfe ihnen kurz.
Legst du dich nochmals hin?
Can I help?
Hoppla.
Jonas hilft in der Küche mit. Er
möchte die Gäste nicht warten lassen.
So, bitte schön.
Vielen Dank.
- Guten Appetit.
Malina liegt ganz zufrieden
hier hinten.
Die Nächte sind natürlich kürzer,
aber ob man
eines mehr oder weniger hat,
ist höchstens in Bezug
auf die Sitzplätze im Auto relevant,
aber ansonsten ...
Wenn ich da bin,
kann ich sie in die Trage legen
oder sie ins Tuch binden
und sie so bei mir haben.
Es ist eher eine Bereicherung
anstatt eine Zusatzbelastung.
Vielleicht für dich,
wegen des Frühstücks.
Die Dinge ändern sich einfach.
Man muss sich
etwas anders organisieren,
aber das ist kein Problem.
Vom Trubel in Schweden
können Alain und Anita
in Griechenland nur träumen.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob sie noch Durst hat.
Ah, sie putzt sich die Füsse, schau.
Während der Hitzewelle hing sie
zum ersten Mal hier am Gitter.
Ich dachte: "Die hat sicher Durst."
Seither kommt sie ab und zu zur Tür,
um zu trinken.
Jetzt hat sie bereits genug.
Gut drei Monate
sind ins Land gezogen.
In Sachen Ferienhäuser aber
herrscht weiterhin Stillstand.
Fütterst du
jetzt noch die Schlangen?
Ja, später.
Dann können sie nach oben umziehen.
Heute bringen wir
die Schlangen nach oben,
in ihr zukünftiges,
definitives Zuhause.
Ich nehme sie raus
und dann kriegen sie noch eine Maus.
Oder zwei bis drei.
Dann können sie nach oben umziehen.
* Rasseln einer Klapperschlange *
Die 24 Klapperschlangen
musste Alain wegen des Brandes
viel länger als geplant
in Holzkisten halten.
Diese sind zwar artgerecht,
entsprechen aber
nicht Alains Anspruch,
wie er die Tiere unterbringen möchte.
Seit über 30 Jahren
beschäftigt er sich mit Reptilien.
Die Schlangen
füttere ich immer einzeln.
Dann gibt es weniger Probleme.
Wenn sich zwei Schlangen
für dieselbe Maus interessieren,
muss man intervenieren.
D.h., man muss
die Schlangen anfassen.
Aber durch jeden Kontakt,
den man vermeiden kann,
ist das Risiko kleiner,
dass ein Unfall geschieht.
* Die Schlange rasselt. *
30 Min. später sind die Giftschlangen
satt und bereit für den Umzug.
Das trifft sich gut, was?
- Ja.
So ist es.
Ah, du hast den Sand
schon gereinigt.- Ja.
Wo andere einen schattigen Sitzplatz
einrichten würden,
haben Alain und Anita
sieben Terrarien gebaut.
So.
* Rasseln der Klapperschlange *
Schau dir das an. Endlich
können auch diese Tiere einziehen.
Das hat ewig gedauert.
- Ganze zwei Jahre.- Mhm.
Schön, nicht wahr?
- Mhm.
Sie werden
den ganzen Tag beschäftigt sein.
Ja, sie wollen wissen, wo sie sind.
- Ja, ja.
Jetzt muss geschnüffelt werden.
- Genau.
Die ersten Klapperschlangen
sind gezügelt -
Zeit für eine Pause.
Willst du noch einen Kaffee?
- Gern.
Achtung.
* Entspannte,
griechisch anmutende Musik *
Nicht nur die Terrarien konnten
Alain und Anita fertigstellen.
Auch ihr Haus ist mittlerweile
wohnlich eingerichtet.
* Entspannte,
griechisch anmutende Musik *
Vor Wochen schon haben sie
ein Geländer für den Balkon bestellt.
Heute soll es endlich
vom Schlosser montiert werden.
Nur - wo bleibt Transporteur Wasilis?
* Rufton *
Er wollte das Geländer
schon vor einer Stunde liefern.
* Rufton *
* Die Verbindung bricht ab. *
Hm!
Nichts.- Nichts?
Vielleicht ist er unterwegs.
Hm, ich glaube, er kommt nicht.
Ansonsten hätte er abgehoben
und gesagt, wann er kommt.
Meinst du, er kommt gar nicht?
- Hm!
Wir werden sehen.
Katze?
Früher in der Schweiz
war das unvorstellbar.
Wenn man um 8 Uhr einen Termin
hatte, war man um 7.55 Uhr dort.
Denn um 8 Uhr kommt der andere.
Und hier ... Tja.
Das ist immer so.
Der Grieche sagt immer: "Avrio".
Das bedeutet "morgen".
D.h. jedoch nicht,
dass er morgen kommt.
D.h. nur, dass er nicht heute kommt.
Das ist einfach so.
Man muss eine gewisse Entspanntheit
an den Tag legen,
sonst dreht man durch.
* Entspannte,
griechisch anmutende Musik *
Kurze Zeit später
kommt dann doch ein Auto.
Kalimera.
- Kalimera.
Es ist der Schlosser.
* Anita spricht griechisch. *
* Anita lacht. *
Er weiss auch nicht, wo Wasilis ist.
Er hat keine Ahnung.
Anita ist irritiert.
Ohne Geländer muss der Schlosser
unverrichteter Dinge wieder abfahren.
* Sie sprechen griechisch. *
Doch dann die Überraschung.
- Das Geländer.
Jetzt kommt definitiv das Geländer.
Offenbar braucht es Wasilis
gar nicht mehr.
Wasilis liegt noch im Bett.
Er hatte wohl
einen anstrengenden Abend.
Er ruft einfach jemand anderen an,
der ein Fahrzeug hat
und hierherkommen kann.
Dann lasse ich euch mal machen. Ich
bringe ein paar Steine nach hinten.
* Entspannte,
griechisch anmutende Musik *
Es ist die griechische Lebensart,
die den Schweizern gefällt und
gleichzeitig so viel Mühe bereitet.
Immerhin: Ein Drittel der Baukosten
haben sie mittlerweile
vom griechischen Staat
erstattet bekommen.
Nun hoffen sie
auf ein weiteres Drittel.
Bevor wir Subventionen erhalten,
muss die Bauabnahme erfolgt sein.
Für die Bauabnahme
war bereits jemand hier.
Er notierte alles,
aber irgendetwas gefällt ihm nicht.
Nun warten wir
seit zweieinhalb Wochen darauf,
dass sich der Architekt
bei uns meldet und uns informiert.
Wir wissen nicht so genau,
was Sache ist.
Das kann wieder Monate dauern.
Das werden wir dann sehen.
Alain und Anita
müssen sich gedulden - einmal mehr.
Barbara und Thomas haben heute einen
besonders arbeitsintensiven Abend.
Ein Paar will sich
in ihrem Gästehaus das Jawort geben.
Das ist unser Öllieferant.
Er fährt den Tankwagen
und bringt uns jeweils Öl.
Ich finde es irgendwie total süss,
dass er anfragte,
ob er bei uns
seine Hochzeit feiern kann.
Deshalb sagten wir Ja.
Der Ort ist zum Heiraten ideal.
Schon oft wurden
Barbara und Thomas angefragt.
Bis auf einmal
haben sie immer Nein gesagt.
* Ruhige Musik *
Zu zweit können sie keine
grosse Festgesellschaft verköstigen.
Auch wenn sie das gerne wollten.
Hochzeiten sind etwas Superschönes.
Was meinst du dazu?
- Wozu?
Die Platten sind süss, nicht?
- Ja.
Aber wir brauchen
noch kleine Gabeln.
Die können wir ja alibimässig
daneben hinlegen.
Wir sind seit bald 20 Jahren
zusammen - ohne zu heiraten.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es so viel Glück bringen würde,
jetzt noch zu heiraten.
Ich warte immer noch auf den Ring.
Ohne Ring keine Hochzeit.
Das ist momentan kein Thema.
Wir haben keine Zeit,
darüber nachzudenken.
Anstatt einem müssen sie heute
zwei mehrgängige Menüs
auf den Tisch zaubern.
Das Geschäft läuft so gut,
dass sie problemlos
Mitarbeiter einstellen könnten.
Seit über einem Jahr
schalten sie Inserate.
(Barbara)
It's not too dry ...
(Frau) Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
Könntest du mir
einen Blueberry Gin machen?
Ja, kann ich.
I think you liked it.
- (Mann) Yeah.
* Lachen *
Ich muss hier noch fertig putzen.
Ich bin noch nicht fertig.
Ein paar Stunden später
ist das Festessen vorbei.
Jetzt müssen Barbara und Thomas
noch aufräumen.
Seit weit über 12 Std.
sind sie auf den Beinen.
Wir hätten uns nie gedacht,
dass wir keine Angestellten finden
und dass wir wirklich
von 6 Uhr morgens bis 23 Uhr
in der Küche oder im Betrieb
sein werden.
Wir müssen das
gar nicht auf uns beziehen.
Nicht nur wir haben Probleme,
Mitarbeiter zu finden,
sondern das ist ein allgemeines
Problem hier in Kanada,
insbesondere auf dieser Insel
bzw. in diesem Teil der Insel.
Aber dass es wirklich so ...
- ... krass ...
... krass herausfordernd ist ...
Aber vielleicht haben wir ja Glück.
Vielleicht finden wir das Juwel,
das bei uns arbeiten will
und das wir einstellen wollen.
Sind wir fertig hier?
- Ja.
Es ist noch nicht mal 23 Uhr.
Wir sind richtig früh dran. Bravo.
Unseren Humor
haben wir noch nicht verloren.
Nein, aber wir haben
für uns als Paar extrem wenig Zeit.
Wenn wir abends um 23 Uhr
oder noch später ins Bett fallen,
bleibt für uns als Paar
keine Zeit mehr.
Das ist ganz klar.
Das kann man nicht schönreden.
Das ist ein Fakt.
Eine andere Herausforderung
müssen drei neue Volontärinnen
von Familie Rotzler
im Skalsjögarden bewältigen.
Die Frauen haben sich bereit erklärt,
den Lagerraum zu sortieren.
Das ist eine Salatschleuder.
* Sie lachen. *
Das Gerümpel hat Familie Rotzler
vom Vorgänger übernommen.
Doch was ist davon noch brauchbar?
Jetzt checkst du es kurz.
Dann sagst du uns,
welche Schrauben und sonstige Dinge
du noch gebrauchen kannst.
# Lass dich überraschen.
Wie willst du vorgehen?
Die Menge an Material
ist auch für Jonas überwältigend.
Du willst die guten Dinge einräumen,
nicht wahr?
Ja, das, was du brauchst.
Genau aussortieren
würde Stunden dauern.
Jonas aber hat Dringenderes zu tun.
Gerda, wollt ihr das einräumen,
was man deiner Meinung nach
noch gebrauchen kann?
Dann schaue ich mir den Rest an.
Ich komme gleich wieder
oder ihr ruft mich.
Das ist ein Tablet-Halter fürs Auto.
Schmeiss es weg!
Du bist also nicht böse, wenn ich
mit meiner Arbeit weitermache?
Ich vertraue auf deine Fähigkeiten.
Auch Sabrina kann nicht helfen.
Sie hat einen Termin bei
der Kinderkrankenschwester in Alfta.
* Kian weint. *
Was ist denn?
Möchtest du ein Buch lesen?
* Kian weint. *
* Sabrina spricht schwedisch. *
Tochter Malina
muss zur Vorsorgeuntersuchung.
(Krankenschwester, Schwedisch)
Mal sehen, ob sie gewachsen ist.
Die Lampen nehmen wir
aber aus den Schachteln.
Aha, ja, ja.
Trotz tatkräftiger Unterstützung -
die Arbeit im Skalsjögarden
geht so schnell nicht aus.
* Jonas seufzt. *
Im Restaurant streikt
seit ein paar Tagen die Lüftung.
Jonas muss auf dem Dach nachsehen.
* Er lacht. *
Das ist scheisse.
Oh mein Gott!
Es kommt immer irgendetwas,
mit dem man nicht gerechnet hat.
Dass eine alte Waschmaschine
irgendwann kaputtgeht, ist ja klar.
Damit hatten wir gerechnet.
Aber dass es noch so viele andere
Themen gibt, kam überraschend.
Gut 40 Jahre hat die Ferienanlage
bereits auf dem Buckel.
Lange hatte der Vorbesitzer
einen Käufer gesucht,
bevor sie
Jonas und Sabrina übernommen haben.
Mit dem Wissen, dass wir eine
stärkere Verhandlungsbasis haben
und dass gewisse Dinge
nicht mehr richtig funktionieren,
würde ich den Preis heute natürlich
noch weiter runterhandeln.
Ich würde
ein paar kleine Dinge anders machen,
aber ich würde es wieder tun.
Der hier interessiert mich weniger.
Der kommt hier unten rein.
Der Motor des Lüfters ist kaputt.
Jonas muss ihn austauschen lassen.
Nein, ich habe keine Zweifel,
ob alles gut wird
oder ob wir
auf dem richtigen Weg sind.
Ich habe irgendwann gemerkt,
dass ich gar keinen Platz
für Ideen habe,
wenn ich mir Sorgen mache,
zweifle und ständig grüble.
Das habe ich von der griechischen
Bevölkerung gelernt:
Sie sind wirklich flexibel,
weil nichts richtig planbar ist.
Okay? Haben wir alles?
- Haben wir alles?
Ja.
Ein Termin
ist fix bei Alain und Anita:
Mittwochs fahren sie gemeinsam
zum Griechischkurs.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Alain und Anita
haben mit vielem gerechnet.
Aber nie
hätten sie sich träumen lassen,
dass in ihrer neuen Heimat
alles so lange dauert.
Noch immer warten sie auf die
Bewilligung für die Ferienhäuser
und die Bauabnahme.
Hier ist unser Architekt.
Wollen wir ihn kurz ansprechen?
Ich kann hier noch wenden.
Tu das.
Die zufällige Begegnung
kommt den beiden gerade recht.
Ich steige kurz aus, okay?
- Mhm.
Der Architekt
soll ihnen endlich sagen,
wie es um die Bauabnahme steht.
Kalimera.
Denn: Ohne die Bauabnahme
bekommen sie kein weiteres Geld.
(Englisch)
Okay.
Also ...
Alain und Anita
wissen offenbar nicht so recht,
wie sie mit dem Architekten
umgehen sollen.
Der hat nicht mal
ein schlechtes Gewissen.- Doch.
Seine Antwort ist für sie
jedenfalls nicht zufriedenstellend.
Erinnerst du mich daran,
am Montag gleich anzurufen?- Mhm.
Danke.
Vermutlich wäre alles viel einfacher,
wenn sie sich mit den Einheimischen
auf Griechisch austauschen könnten.
Doch bis dahin
ist es noch ein weiter Weg.
Kalispera.
- (Mann) Hello.
In der Strandbar eines Hotels
treffen sie Christos.
Seit zwei Jahren
ist er ihr Griechischlehrer.
(Englisch)
(Griechisch)
Ah, mit i, nicht mit ...
- Quitten.
(Englisch)
* Er spricht griechisch. *
Akoma? Das heisst "noch ein".
Akoma mia ...
- ... bira.
* Anita lacht triumphierend. *
Bitte noch ...
- Nein.
... noch einmal ein Bier.
- Bravo. Noch, ja. Akoma.
(Englisch)
* Anita und Alain lachen. *
Sie sprechen so schnell - schwups,
schon haben sie zehn Worte gesagt.
Yes.
- Und dann ...
Ich dachte, Griechisch zu lernen,
würde mir viel leichter fallen.
Ich mag Sprachen eigentlich
total gern und lerne sie leicht,
aber Griechisch
ist wirklich schwierig.
Man muss eigentlich
jedes Wort lernen,
weil man keinen Vergleich hat.
Es gibt kein Wort,
das ähnlich klingt,
ausser die griechischen Wörter,
die wir auch benutzen.
Der Rest
ist einfach komplett anders.
Okay.
* Er spricht griechisch. *
* Griechisch anmutende Melodie
von "Uf u dervo" *
Good morning.
(Barbara)
Züpfe-Weggli.
Manchmal lösen sich Probleme anders,
als man denkt.
Seit ein paar Tagen
hat Barbara Hilfe von Claire.
Sie arbeitete früher
bei uns auf der Post.
Dann verlor sie ihren Job.
Das war für uns die perfekte Chance.
Wir konnten ja
wirklich niemanden finden.
Jetzt kann sie
bereits selbstständig arbeiten.
Nun kann ich mich zurückziehen
und Büroarbeit machen.
Das ist für uns natürlich Gold wert.
Yes, they're great.
Ganz loslassen
kann Barbara aber noch nicht.
(Barbara)
Nicht nur bei den Gipfeli
hat Barbara klare Vorstellungen,
auch bei der Menüplanung
für die kommenden Tage.
Risotto mit Scallops, dann ...
... Schweinsfilet mit potatoes.
Das klingt nicht schlecht.
Das sind jetzt fünf.
Bleibt jemand nächste Woche
länger als fünf Tage?
No, I don't.
Ich muss Allergiker unterbringen
und schauen,
was ich für so viele Leute
allein zubereiten kann.
Und ich muss darauf achten,
dass es keine Wiederholung gibt
oder dass wir nicht
zweimal hintereinander Pasta
oder Kartoffeln servieren.
Das füllt mir im Moment den Kopf.
* Ruhige Musik *
Bei Claire weiss Barbara
das Frühstück in guten Händen.
Früher als sonst
hat sie Zeit für einen Einkauf.
Sie fährt ins nächste Dorf,
nach St. Peters Bay -
eine willkommene Abwechslung.
Hi, hi.
- (Mann) How's it going?- Good.
Und selbst?
- Auch gut.
Ich hole mir bei dir einen Kaffee
und dann muss ich
bei Julio Scallops abholen.
Ein Besuch bei Mike
gehört für Barbara dazu.
Thank you so much.
Der Auswanderer
betreibt mehrere Cafés.
Bei euch ist es auch busy, was?
- Nein, zurzeit nicht.
Wir schliessen am Dienstag.
Nachdem die Gäste ausgecheckt haben,
checkt niemand mehr ein.
Deshalb werden es weniger.
Das ist gut. Dann habt ihr
auch mal ein paar Tage frei.
Nein, wir schliessen am Dienstag
und öffnen am Mittwoch wieder.
Auch im Fischmarkt
kennt man Barbara schon gut.
Hi.
Thank you very much.
- You're welcome.
Der Sommer lief richtig gut an.
Ja, er lief gut an, aber im Juli ...
Es läuft gut, aber wir hatten
bisher einfach kein gutes Wetter.
Das merkt man.
Wir haben auf der Anlage
immer noch viele Investitionskosten.
Damit wir alles reparieren
und den Unterhalt zukunftsorientiert
gestalten könnten,
ohne die Systeme
ans Limit zu fahren,
und damit wir defekte Lüftungen
komplett ersetzen könnten usw.,
bräuchten wir noch mehr Einnahmen.
Also, nun bereiten wir es kurz vor.
Einmal pro Woche
findet man Sabrina und Jonas
den ganzen Tag im Restaurant.
Dann sind sie
nicht nur für das Frühstück,
sondern auch für Mittag-
und Abendessen verantwortlich.
Das Küchenteam
braucht ja auch einen freien Tag.
Daher machen wir es so,
dass wir am Montag
jeweils im Restaurant stehen,
damit das Küchenteam
auch einen freien Tag hat.
Das ist alkoholfrei.
- Aha.
Wollen Sie eins mit Alkohol?
- Ja, gerne.
Das Restaurant zu schliessen
ist für die Rotzlers während
der Hauptsaison keine Alternative.
Danke.
Wir hatten eigentlich nicht geplant,
diesen Küchentag
selbst zu übernehmen.
Das merken wir natürlich,
aber es ist okay.
Die Kinder
sind entweder um uns herum
oder sonst
dürfen sie auch mal fernsehen.
(Schwedisch)
Stimmt die Temperatur der Lasagne?
Sabrina?
- Wie?- Stimmt die Temperatur?
Vielleicht müssen wir sie
reduzieren.- Nein, erhöhen.
Aber nicht, dass sie schwarz wird.
- 180 °C. Sie wird nicht schwarz.
Für ihren Traum von der
Selbstständigkeit sind sie bereit,
grossen Einsatz zu bringen.
Die Idee wäre schon, dass irgendwann
der Tag kommt, an dem wir ...
... nicht mehr
so intensiv gebraucht werden.
Vielleicht werden wir
schon noch jeden Tag gebraucht,
aber es wäre schon schön,
wenn es etwas ruhiger werden würde.
Haben wir nur noch Dill?
Wo ist das andere ...
Da fragst du die Falsche.
Verdammt, sie haben es neu sortiert.
Jetzt finde ich nichts mehr.
Es ist super,
dass sie alles umgestellt haben.
Gehackte Petersilie. Danke schön.
- Gehackte Petersilie.
* Sanfte Musik *
Kaum ein Jahr ist es her,
dass Familie Rotzler
die Ferienanlage übernommen hat.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich glaube, im Grossen und Ganzen
kriegten wir es relativ gut hin.
Hier fand zuvor eigentlich
keine Geschäftstätigkeit mehr statt.
Es lief nichts mehr.
Hier lief jahrelang nichts.- Ja.
In Anbetracht dessen können wir mit
dem Geschäft, wie es heute läuft,
ziemlich zufrieden sein.
Auch die Kinder fühlen sich wohl.
Das ist für mich das Wichtigste.
Wir sind innerlich
spürbar zufriedener.
Das möchten wir beibehalten.
Das Geschäft sollte so gut laufen,
dass wir weitermachen können.
Wir wünschen uns, dass unsere Idee,
hier zu leben, funktioniert.
Genau.
(Schwedisch)
* Sanfte Musik *
Der zweite Sommer in Schweden
erscheint vielversprechend.
Tschüss, gute Fahrt.
- Tschüss zusammen. Danke, tschau.
Mit Tatkraft,
guten Ideen und Gelassenheit
könnte der Plan
für Familie Rotzler aufgehen.
Halt dich fest.
Ui,
jetzt fällst du aber bald runter.
Nicht mehr?
- (Kind) Nein.
Ausschwingen lassen?
Das mit dem Geld macht einen -
oder zumindest mich -
schon ein bisschen nervös.
Aber andererseits lernen wir
hier und da jeweils Leute kennen
und dann ergeben sich immer
wieder kleine Einnahmequellen.
Das ist ja auch nicht schlecht.
Damit hatten wir
gar nicht gerechnet.
Aber grundsätzlich
bin ich schon nervöser als sie.
Ich denke manchmal schon: "Puh,
klappt das wohl mit dem Geld?"
Aber das sind
nur ganz kurze Momente,
da ich den Gedanken,
wie wir es schaffen,
genügend Geld zu verdienen,
mehr Raum lassen will.
Der Kummer darüber,
dass wir zu wenig haben,
soll nicht die Oberhand gewinnen.
* Muntere Klänge *
Die angenehmen Temperaturen
des griechischen Spätsommers
könnten fast ein wenig
darüber hinwegtäuschen,
dass die Situation
bei Alain und Anita
alles andere als paradiesisch ist.
Wo eigentlich Ferienhäuser stehen
sollten, ist weiterhin Brachland.
Wir würden hier bei uns
sehr gern Gäste unterbringen.
Vor ein paar Tagen erhielten wir
gerade eine Anfrage von jemandem,
der hier vielleicht seinen
Ferienwohnwagen aufstellen möchte.
Da alles so unsicher ist,
sind wir offen für neue Ideen.
Das wächst jetzt.
So langsam müssen sie umdenken.
* Sie macht ein Lockgeräusch. *
Essen, hm? Gehen wir essen?
Du zumindest.
* Miauen, Lockgeräusche *
So.
Wir kriegen heute noch Campinggäste.
Nun putze ich noch das Sanitärhaus,
die Küche und das Bad,
damit es für sie angenehm ist.
Ganz wichtig
sind die Fenster mit Meerblick.
Das ist das Highlight.
Das Sanitärhaus
nutzten Alain und Anita
während des Baus
als Küche und Badezimmer.
Zukünftig soll es
Campinggästen zur Verfügung stehen.
Alain hat die Gäste aus der Schweiz
unten an der Hauptstrasse getroffen,
um ihnen den Weg zu zeigen.
Die Strecke zu ihrem Grundstück
ist nicht so leicht zu finden
und führt
über steile Schotterstrassen.
Tschau, Anita.
- Hallo, ich bin Küsu.
Hallo, Küsu.
- Karin.- Hallo, Karin.
Zuerst wollte ich fahren, aber
ich bin froh, dass ich es nicht tat.
Ich kenne das Gefühl, wenn man
froh ist, nicht am Steuer zu sitzen.
Aber wenn man mal oben ist,
ist es herrlich, was?- Ja.
Brauchst du Strom?
- Nein.
Du brauchst nichts?
Markus und Karin
kommen aus dem Emmental.
Über private Kontakte haben sie
von den Auswanderern gehört.
(Karin) Halt, halt!
18 Euro kostet der Stellplatz
für die beiden.
Nicht viel,
aber zumindest ein Zustupf.
Habt ihr Basilikum mitgenommen?
- Ja, natürlich.
Wir leben nach dem Motto: "Wir haben
keine Kinder, keine Hunde,
aber dafür Basilikum."
In Kanada müssen Barbara und Thomas
nur noch einen Abend durchhalten.
Dann haben sie endlich
einen Tag frei.
Schau mal, wie schön.
Heute haben sie nur zwei Gäste.
Eine gute Gelegenheit für Barbara,
ein neues Rezept mit Meeresfrüchten
auszuprobieren.
(Barbara)
Auch Thomas muss testen.
Das Gericht
sollte nicht nur gut schmecken,
sondern auch schnell sein
in der Zubereitung.
Hm?
- Ja.
Ein Bier und fast 1 l Weisswein.
Man kann es super einfach
in grossen Mengen zubereiten.
Man macht einfach die Sauce,
legt die Muscheln rein,
wartet, bis sie aufgehen,
und dann gibt man alles andere dazu.
Mhm.
- That's it.
(Barbara)
Die Pasta mit Meeresfrüchten wird
Barbara in ihren Menüplan aufnehmen.
Der einzige Wehrmutstropfen ist -
aber ich glaube, das ist für
alle so, die auf und davon gehen -,
dass die Familie nicht hier ist.
Die Familie und Freunde sind ja ein
wichtiger Bestandteil des Zuhauses.
Das haben wir nicht.
* Ruhige Musik *
Die Gäste sind abgereist,
die Zimmer geputzt.
Jetzt ist er endlich da,
der freie Tag.
Es ist so schön ruhig.
Alle Fischerboote sind hier.
Sie sind in Naufrage Harbour,
einem beliebten Ort
für Hummerfischer.
Hello.
- Hi.
(Barbara)
Anstatt in ein feines Restaurant
gehen Barbara und Thomas
zu einem Imbiss.
Sie wollen sehen, ob sie ihn
den Gästen empfehlen können.
Hier ist es noch trocken.
Hier kannst du sitzen.
Cheers, auf den ersten
freien Abend ...- Ja.
... seit ... Puh.
... Monaten.
- Sehr zum Wohl.
Hast du gehört?
Auf den freien Abend.
Vor zwei Jahren sind sie
nach Kanada aufgebrochen.
Ihre Vision: ein Gästehaus am Meer.
Mit Fleiss und Durchhaltevermögen
konnten sie
ihren Traum verwirklichen -
trotz aller Hindernisse.
Ich glaube, niemand kann uns
überkandidelte Ansprüche nachsagen -
an die generelle Situation.
Hallo, das ist eine Lobster Roll.
Nein, genau genommen Lobster Burger.
Aber es ist lecker.
- Die Pommes sind super.- Mhm.
Ich würde es wieder und wieder tun.
Ja.
- Ja.
Es ist noch nicht alles so,
wie es sein sollte oder könnte,
aber ich denke, das ...
... ist ein Stück weit auch normal.
Es kann sich
alles sehr schnell ändern.
Das sahen wir ja durch Fiona und so.
- Richtig.
Aber wir fühlen uns hier wohl,
wir haben ein Einkommen
und ein Dach über dem Kopf.
Daher sieht vieles positiv aus.
Ihr Konzept mit dem Gästehaus
ging voll auf.
Der Wunsch für die Zukunft
hingegen ist bescheiden.
Mehr solche Tage wie heute.
- Ja.
Damit wir einfach mal sagen können:
"Sorry, the hotel is closed.
We will be open tomorrow again."
Ja.
Ein grosser Wunsch von uns ist,
dass das Gesetz gekippt wird
und dass wir
eine Bewilligung erhalten.
Diese Häuser bauen zu können und
die Gäste hier oben zu begrüssen,
wäre für uns
die bei Weitem einfachste Variante.
Das ist ein grosser Wunsch von mir.
Ja, und dass es gelingt,
dass wir hierbleiben können.- Mhm.
Das Schlimmste wäre,
wenn das Projekt misslingen,
wenn wir verkaufen und wieder
woandershin weiterziehen müssten.
Bei Alain und Anita
ist weiterhin alles offen.
* Piepton *
Gut.
Werden sie die Ferienhäuschen
wie gewünscht bauen können?
Finden sie genug Reisegruppen,
die bei ihnen Touren buchen?
Oder müssen sie ganz neue Wege gehen?
Diese Fragen lassen sich
noch nicht beantworten.
Hier ist es super.
Klar ist:
Alain und Anita bereuen es nicht,
den Schritt zum Auswandern
gewagt zu haben.
Danach gehen wir dann baden.
Wir haben hier die Ruhe
und Gelassenheit gefunden,
die wir uns erhofft haben.
Wir mussten lernen, dass es auf uns
und nicht auf die Umgebung ankommt,
dass wir umdenken müssen.
Hier haben wir
die besten Voraussetzungen,
um das zu verwirklichen und
dort anzukommen, wo wir hinwollten.
Hier geht alles einen ruhigeren Gang
und man muss selbst ruhiger werden.
Wenn man will, dass alles
so schnell geht wie in der Schweiz,
wird man verrückt.
Das geht nicht.
Ein toller Nebeneffekt für mich.
* Muntere Klänge *
Ich werfe es zu dir.
Ich habe es zumindest versucht.
* Muntere Klänge *
Und so geht es weiter
mit "Auf und davon":
Familie Tscharner
ist durch und durch Fan der USA.
Wir können es noch kaum glauben.
- Jetzt wohnen wir am Meer.
Sie ziehen nach Florida.
Oh, der Schulbus!
Tochter Lily Rose
hat ihren ersten Schultag.
Oh nein!
- Bye-bye.
Doch dieser läuft ordentlich schief.
Sie ist in der 2. Klasse,
nicht in der 1. Klasse.
Mit Immobilien will Familie Tscharner
Geld verdienen.
Unsere Geschäftsidee ist der Umbau
von nicht so tollen Häusern,
die jedoch Rohdiamanten sind.
An Freude und Tatkraft
fehlt es ihnen nicht.
Doch werden sie
auch wirtschaftlich erfolgreich sein?
Gib Vollgas, Papa.
Leben, wo andere Ferien machen.
Das ist der Traum von Otmar Gemperli
und seinem Partner Gabor Balogh.
Otmar übernimmt auf Mallorca
ein Restaurant.
Ich investiere wirklich alles,
was ich habe, in dieses Projekt.
Sie bauen eigenhändig um.
Der Zeitplan ist eng,
bald liegen die Nerven blank.
Ihr habt einfach
die Aufkleber entfernt.
Ja.- Ja,
und jetzt hat er sich wehgetan.
Jetzt haben wir geöffnet.
Die Gäste können kommen.
Einmal komplett öffnen.
Für Gabor
ist es ein völlig neuer Job.
Als ich die Tabletts hielt,
hat meine Hand gezittert.
Eine turbulente Zeit beginnt -
halten sie den Stress durch?
Und ab in den wilden Norden.
Isabelle und Steff Felix sind
der rauen Natur Islands verfallen.
Was gibt es Schöneres?
Ihre Ferien-Lodge
erweitern sie um drei Tiny-Häuser.
Gleichzeitig läuft der Gästebetrieb
und der Bautrupp muss bekocht werden.
Die Zimmerleute gehen,
die Arbeit bleibt.
Wir sind aufeinander angewiesen.
Wir sind ein Zweierteam.
Das Liebespaar wird zum Arbeitsteam -
eine ausserordentliche Erfahrung.
Die neue Staffel: ab Freitag,
5. Januar um 21 Uhr auf SRF 1.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2024
# Uf u dervo, yeah.